WELCOME TO THE APPROPRIATIONS.
COMMITTEE FOR MAY SIXTEENTH
NOTING THE ABSENCE OF WARMER AND
STARTED SUBCOMMITTEE AND I SEE A.
DOCTOR WEBER NEEDS TO GO FIRST
SO WE WILL.
ENTERTAIN MY SISTER FROM SAN
DIEGO.
TELLING ME SHE'S GOING FIRST.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF I HAVE A BUDGET
COMMITTEE I HAVE TO CHEER THIS
MORNING SO I WOULD HAVE GRATEFUL
TO BE ABLE TO GO FIRST.
I'M HERE THIS MORNING TO
PRESENT TO AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
TWO WHICH IS CALLED THE CAN'T
WORK IF YOU'RE HUNGRY AT.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TO REQUIRE
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH A HOME
WITH THRESHOLD THAT WILL
IDENTIFY WHEN A PERSON IS TWO
HUNDRED TO BE EMPLOYABLE.
ONCE IN PLACE A PERSON WHO
SCREAMED AS BEING UNFIT FOR WORK
DUE TO HUNGER WILL BE
TEMPORARILY EXEMPT FROM THE
THREE MONTH TIME LIMIT.
THIS WOULD NOT ONLY HELP THEM
PREVENT HUNGER BUT KEEPS FEDERAL
ANTI HUNGER BENEFITS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. CREATING JOBS AND
GENERATING ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
OUR STATES FOOD ECONOMY. THE
COST IS MINIMAL TO THE STATE
THIS BILL PASSED ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. HERE WITH ME
TODAY THE TESTIFIES JESSICA
BARTOLO OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY.
THE BILL SPONSOR TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JUST NORTH OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ARE SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL. AND NOT
MUCH TO ADD FROM THE MEMBER'S
COMMENTS EXCEPT FOR TO SAY THAT
HUNGER HAS NEVER MADE ANYBODY.
THE BETTER AT ANYTHING AND THAT
INCLUDES WORK.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS THRESHOLD
MEASUREMENT WILL HELP US
IDENTIFY WHEN SOMEBODY IS
EXPERIENCING EXTREME HUNGER AND
THEREFORE UNABLE TO WORK AND
NEED FOOD ASSISTANCE IN ORDER TO
GET THEM BACK TO A PLACE. WHERE
THEY CAN WORK AND RECONNECT
SEVEN WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
THROUGH SNAP CURRENTLY IN THIRTY
TWO COUNTIES?
OUT WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE AND I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU OTHER ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I KNOW FILE.
SEE NO COMMENTS WE WILL TAKE
THAT UP WHEN WE GET A QUORUM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MISTER HOLDEN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO.
ALRIGHT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
MISTER HOLDEN WILL BE PRESENTING
ON A BETWEEN NINETY TEAM IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WHEN WE GET A PART OF.
THANK YOU RATHER CHAIR OF.
AND MEMBERS IT'S PLEASURE TO BE
BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING AT
PRESENT TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
INCLUDE. AND THE CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S HANDBOOK INFORMATION
REGARDING THE PERSON CIVIL
RIGHTS DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
THE DRIVER'S HANDBOOK INCLUDES
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO CONDUCT
ONCE
SELF DURING A STOP.
BUT STOP SHORT OF STATING THE
RIGHTS
THE DRIVER AND WHAT TO DO IF THE
SITUATION ESCALATES.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN SO
ADDRESS THE EXTENT AND
LIMITATIONS OF A PEACE OFFICER
IS A STORY DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
BELIEVING LEGAL RIGHTS OF A
DRIVER AND PASSENGERS AND
DETAILS ON THE PROCESS FOR
FILING COMPLAINTS AGAINST A
PEACE OFFICER.
THE COST IS MINOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIGHT.
THANK YOU EITHER SPEAKER SINCE
PART.
BECAUSE IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. BUT NO
FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
ARE SORT LESS RELIABLE AND WHAT
AT THE FULL THAT UP WHEN I WE
GET QUITE. HE WAS TO HOLD AND
BAKER
.
SO MISTER TING GREAT COME ON UP.
MR TEAM WILL BE PRESENTING AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY TAIL IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO IT'S OKAY
A VERY I'LL BE VERY CAR QUICKIE
BETWEEN NINE FORTY TWO ALLOWS
PROSECUTORS. THE DISCRETION TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR RECALL
AND RE SENSING OF DEFENDANTS
PROVIDED THAT THE DEFENDANT'S
BEHAVIOR IS NOT A THREAT.
TO PUBLIC SAFETY IN THAT THERE'S
EVIDENCE INDICATING THE
REHABILITATION AND THIS GIVES.
FULL DISCRETION TO PROSECUTORS
DOES NOT OBLIGATE THEM TO DO
ANYTHING.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE I I HAD A WITNESS BUT
OF COURSE SHE IS STUCK IN
TRAFFIC.
IT HAPPENS YES.
ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
ANY OPPONENTS.
BERMAN FINANCE NO FROM THE FILE.
ALRIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU DISRESPECT THAT'S
RIGHT UP WILL TAKE THAT UP WHEN
WE GET ONE.
A GREAT TO GET SOME MEMBERS DOWN
HERE IF YOU HAVE A BILL.
MR FUNG.
MISTER GALLAGHER OF MISS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER I GUESS I WILL
BRING.
NEXT.
MADAM CHAIR YOU HAVE TO.
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX.
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR A. BETWEEN FOR
NINETY SIX WILL PROTECT PROPERTY
SERVICE WORKERS FROM
UNSCRUPULOUS. COMPANIES WHO SEEK
DEBATE BASIC WORKER PROTECTION
LAWS BY MISS CLASSIFYING THEM
THIS BILL HAS MINIMAL STATE
COSTS HAS RECEIVED STRONG
SUPPORT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION RESPECT LAST
NIGHT.
DO YOU HAVE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE FROM THE AUDIENCE WISHING
TO ADDRESS IN SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOVA.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR FROM
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
WELL WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM
CHAIR.
BUT WE WILL TAKE THIS ONE UP.
WE HAVE.
WE.
WHEN WE COME.
MA'AM SAID SHAKING PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER PRESENT
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRO.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
SHALL.
EGGMAN.
PHONE.
FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER. GARCIA.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE. QUIRK.
HERE RISKS.
I WILL NOTE THAT AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY SIX BY MR FONG WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR.
WE WERE NOT HEARING NOT.
.
MISS GRANTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
AB TWENTY ONE OF SEVEN
.
MR ASSISTANT I DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ONCE WE GET OUT
W. HAVE.
ONCE AGAIN THIS. YEAR. THINK IF
I MOWED THE BILL JUST.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN UPDATES THE
LAWS GOVERNING THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURES.
AND FRANCHISE NEW CAR DEALERS TO
BRING EQUITY TO THIS VITAL
RELATIONSHIP.
NEW CAR DEALERS OPERATING AS
LOCAL INDEPENDENTLY OWNED
FRANCHISED DEALERSHIPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES CREATE LOCAL JOBS.
AND HELP SPUR LOCAL ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
IF WE AS A STATE ARE GOING TO
MEET OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF LOW
EMISSION AND ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD WE MUST
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS. ARE NOT PUT AT A
DISADVANTAGE IN RELATION TO THE
OUT OF STATE.
AUTOMAKERS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THE BALANCE
OF POWER BETWEEN LARGE
MULTINATIONAL AUTO MAKERS AND
CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR DEALERS IS
A FAIR AND COMPETITIVE PLAYING
FIELD.
AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN CONTAINS
NUMEROUS PROVISIONS TO ADDRESS
SEVERAL KEY ISSUES THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA CAR
DEALERS ARE PROTECTED. AND IN
TURN THAT CONSUMERS WILL BE
PROTECTED.
WITH ME TODAY.
IS CLIFF COSTA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
SUPPORT.
MEN CHAIR MEMBERS CLUB BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION.
WHEN WE FIRST CATCH MY BREATH.
LITTLE RENDON FROM UPSTAIRS.
ANIMAL BE GUY SO GIVE ME A
SECOND HERE.
.
I LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR WHEN
I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR.
THEIR WORK ON THE BILL I ONE
THINK THE CHAIR FOR.
THE VICE CHAIR FOR MEETING WITH
US AND TALKING ABOUT IT.
FRANCHISE BILLS ARE IMPORTANT
NOT JUST NEW CAR DEALERS.
TO CONSUMERS INTO THE STATE.
IT IS WIDELY FRANCHISE LAWS HAVE
BEEN AROUND SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE.
EVERY FEW YEARS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE STEPS IN TO HELP.
ADDRESS THE INHERENT POWER
IMBALANCE BETWEEN US.
THE LOCALLY OWNED INDEPENDENT.
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES IN THE
INTERNATIONAL AUTOMAKERS.
AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN IS NOT
DIFFERENT FROM PREVIOUS
FRANCHISE BILLS.
THE ADDRESS.
CIVIC AUTOMAKER BEHAVIOR.
BEHAVIOR THAT WE BELIEVE
UNDERMINES.
LOOSE OF RIGHTS OF THE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS THAT WE HAVE SIGNED
MANY MANY YEARS AGO.
SINCE THIS IS OUR FISCAL
COMMITTEE HAD LIKE TO FOCUS ON
THE PHYSICAL ASPECT OF THE BILL.
ACCORDING TO YOUR ANALYSIS.
THE BILL ONE MORE MINUTE.
MINOR COSTS.
.
WE.
ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER POLICY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM.
THE BILL IS QUITE COMPLICATED ON
THE POLICY SIDE WE HAVE A ROBUST
HEARING IN ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
POLICY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE BUT I
THINK THE FISCAL QUESTIONS ARE
PRETTY CLEAR IT'S MINOR COSTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST ON SUPPORT MADAM
CHAIR JAMES AMMAR'S SENIOR
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
DEALERS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE VERY
SIMILAR PROBLEMS TO THE AUTO
DEALERS AND. AT TRYING TO DEAL
WITH MAJOR CORPORATIONS SUCH AS
HONDA. BMW OUT OF ORDER SEVERE
GIFTS ISN'T PACKAGE THANK YOU
LOW COST FISCALLY WE PAY FOR IT
THROUGH OUR FEES THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
PERRANCE I WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
THAT.
EACH SIDE WILL HAVE TO FOLKS
WHO CAN DO UP TO TWO MINUTES
EACH.
AND PLEASE TRY TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO FISCAL MATTERS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BELIEVE GLORIA WERE PERSONAL MY
CALIFORNIA. MOTORCYCLE INSTITUTE
RECREATIONAL HEALTH CLUB OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLES AND THE
SPECIALLY VEHICLE INSTITUTE. IF
YOU LISTEN TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS OPENING REMARKS.
HAVE YOU READ THE ANALYSIS OF
BERKELEY AND ISSUE.
WE TING.
NEW CAR MANUFACTURER FOR NEW CAR
DEALERS UNFORTUNATELY WILL WEIGH
THE CULT GOES. MOTORCYCLE
MANUFACTURERS GET INCLUDED NOT
TO.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR JUST TO GET ON
REMEMBER TO EXEMPT MOTORCYCLE.
.
MANUFACTURERS FROM THE ISSUE.
WILL NO PROBLEM WHAT THE NEW
CARDINALS ARE DO WE WANT TO BE
INCLUDED BECAUSE FOR A.
FRANCHISE AGREEMENT THAT THEY
WORK OUT WITH A NEW CAR
MANUFACTURER PASTURES MAY NOT
WORK. FOR MOTORCYCLE
MANUFACTURERS THANK YOU.
YOU IRVINE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS AND THEN FOCUS ON
COSTS WITH ONE EXCEPTION THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO. WITH ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES WE MAKE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES.
WE'VE INVESTED TENS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
THE DEALER SAU SOME SUGGEST
POORLY BUT WE ARE THE ONES WHO
MAKE THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY SELL.
WITH REGARD TO COSTS THE BILL IS
DESIGNED.
PURPOSEFULLY DESIGNED TO UNLEASH
A FLOOD OF PROTESTS.
AT THE NEW MOTORCYCLE VEHICLE
BOARD.
TO DETERMINE GRANDIOSE ISSUES OF
MARKET SHARE. WHO CAN
PARTICIPATE WHO CAN NOT
PARTICIPATE?
IT WILL DETERMINE WHETHER
EXISTING LEGAL RELATIONSHIPS ARE
SUDDENLY UNLAWFUL BY YOUR VOTE
TAKE DAY. THIS WILL HAVE
DRAMATIC EFFECTS.
ON THE ECONOMY ON THE NEW MOTOR
VEHICLE BOARD AND IT WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY REPOSITIONED THE
BALANCE OF INFLUENCE AND POWER
IN THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD.
IT IS NOT MINOR IT IS MAJOR
MAJOR STUFF NO ONE INCLUDING THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE HAVE
BECOME MAY END OF WHAT IS IN
THIS BILL. WE WOULD ASK YOU TO
VOTE NO THANK YOU.
THINK USER ADDITION OPPOSITION
URINATION ORGANIZATION MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS IVAN ALL TOMORROW
BEHALF OF GLOBAL AUTOMAKERS I'M
JUST A LINE.
I MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MISTER URBAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY DISH OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. LEVEL.
REMOVED MEMBER QUESTIONS MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ASSEMBLY
WOMAN REYES AYE I AGREE WITH YOU
pTHAT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S
WORTHY OF OUR.
OF ARE WEIGHING IN ON SO I'M A
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. I
APPLAUD YOU FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU HAD WITH
THE OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY ARE ONGOING. OF THE BILL
STILL SEEMS A LITTLE BIT HEAVY
HANDED TO ME AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AS MOVES FORWARD SO
WE GET SOMETHING MUCH OF THAT
MORE BALLOTS WHEN IT COMES TO
THE FLOOR.
VERY GOOD.
MR BELOW.
YEAH.
JUST LIKE MISTER OBERNOLTE SAID.
YOU JUST HEARD SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE AND I
THINK YOU'RE PRETTY FAMILIAR
WITH A NUMBER OF THE CONCERNS
THAT ARE BEING RAISED BY THEM.
MANUFACTURES.
IT'S OUR LEVEL OF. UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BUILD A
NETWORK WITH THEM AND CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM TO TRY TO
REFINE MAY NOT GET A FULL BRIDGE.
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU BUT.
TO GIVE SOME. CONSIDERATION.
HERE AND MAYBE GET SOME
AGREEMENT ON A FEW.
ISSUES THAT CAN BE TIGHTENED UP.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK WE'VE MADE
THAT COMMITMENT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
ONE THIS WAS PRESENTED AND
JUDICIARY.
WE CONTINUE TO MEET WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND AS LATE AS LAST
NIGHT. WE DISCUSSED THE FACT
THAT WE WILL BE MEETING AGAIN TO
CONTINUE THE DISK.
SO MANY OF REFER THE QUESTION TO
THE OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE THE
SAME LEVEL OF COMMITMENT FROM
YOU. TO OBTAIN SOME OF THESE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT ARE.
PERHAPS AND FIND COMPROMISE
GROUND
FROM MY SINGLE.
WORK.
THE MOST ASK HONEST ANSWERS
PERHAPS NOT.
I'M WE HAVE REPEATEDLY ASKED THE
DEALERS TO IDENTIFY THE TWO OR
THREE ISSUES OF IMPORTANCE TO
THEM.
NOT THE TWENTY FIVE ISSUES THAT
ARE NOW IN THE BILL BUDGET
TWENTY FIVE THAT WERE REGIONALLY
AND.
WE ARE NOT IN THE POSITION TO
REWARD CONDUCT WHERE YOU PUT
SOMETHING STUPID AND UPHILL
THROW IT OUT ANDASK YOU TO BE
COMMENDED WE CAN'T DO THAT. IF
THEY IDENTIFIED THE TWO OR THREE
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
THAT WE HAVE NEGOTIATED IN THE
PAST WHICH
BILL RE OPENS.
WE ARE PREPARED TO DO THAT BUT
NOT THE SWEET BEING ECONOMY WHY
CHANGES THAT THEY ARE PROPOSING
IN THIS.
I APPRECIATE THE BRAVADO THAT
YOU HAVE IN THE.
AND THE FEELINGS THAT YOU HAVE.
I WOULD PREFER TO HEAR MORE YES
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH BUT.
UNFORTUNATELY I SEE THAT YOU'RE
PROBABLY AT A POINT OF THE
IMPASSE.
AND IT IS A PLACE WHERE LIKE MR
A MOMENT HE JUST SAT WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE MUST WAIT.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH AYE AND.
WILL WORK BEST ON ANOTHER ONE.
AND.
MISTER BIG. IS THERE NOW. MISTER
BONTA.
BUT I AM.
THANK YOU TO THE OTHER FOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORTY HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION I'M I'M SORT OF
TRY TO CATCH UP ON THE DIFFERENT
PIECES OF THE BILL I JUST HAD. A
COUPLE QUICK CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS. M..
IS THERE A COMPONENT OF THE BILL
THE OUTLAWS SUBSCRIPTION
SERVICES FOR CARS AND AND AND
AND IF SO P. Q. TALK LIVE ABOUT
THE THINKING BEHIND THAT AND IF
THERE'S A OUTLAW THEM BUT I'M
GOING TO ALLOW. IT IT WITH
CHAIRS PERMISSION TO HAVE MISTER
COSTER RESPOND TO THAT I KNOW
THAT HAS BEEN ONE OF THE.
.
COMPLAINTS THAT. CLAIM THAT ANY
CLARIFICATION WE HELP THE S..
GREAT QUESTION MR BONTA OUT OF
THE BILL SPECIFICALLY SAYS ARE
IN SUBDIVISION ó OF THE BILL
AND I. PUT A BUILDING WHICH P.
LIKE SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE
LANGUAGE SAYS IS THAT IF YOU'RE
A MANUFACTURER AND A FRANCHISE
OR.
VIN YOU CANNOT SELL SERVICE.
SO LEASE OR SUBSCRIBE VEHICLES
WITHOUT. UNLESS YOU USE
EXCLUSIVELY YOUR FRANCHISE DE.
SO.
MANY OF THE MANUFACTURERS ARGUE
THAT WE BAND SUBSCRIPTION
PROGRAMS
OUR RESPONSES IS NO WE'RE NOT
WE'RE SAYING THAT ALL MEAN THAT
YOU HAVE TO USE YOUR LOCAL
FRANCHISE. HE'S IN THE PROCESS
OF DOING SUBSCRIPTIONS
YOU HAVE FRANCHISEES IN EVERY
SINGLE COMMUNITY WE HAVE A FLEET
OF CARS THAT WE PURCHASED FROM
YOU. USE US THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE FOR PLEASE DON'T COMPETE
AGAINST US
THAT'S WHAT THE THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL SETS UP INDIANA FOR
EXAMPLE ACTUALLY PUT A ONE YEAR
MORATORIUM SAYING. CAR
SUBSCRIPTIONS CAN NOT OCCUR IN
THE STATE OF INDIANA THAT'S
CLEARLY NOT WHAT OUR LANGUAGE
SAYS HERE
WHAT WE'RE SAYING THIS IS JUST
USUAL LOCAL DEALERS.
IF YOU'RE GONNA DO SUBSCRIPTION
PROGRAMS
SOME MANUFACTURERS LIKE MERCEDES
BMW AND NOW CADILLAC ARE ROLLING
OUT THESE PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE
USING DEALERS BUT NOT ALL ARE
AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT COMPETE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
UP ANOTHER AREA WHERE WAS I
COULD USE A LITTLE CLARIFICATION
IS ABOUT THAT THE RELEVANT
MARKET AREA AND
THE DEFINITION IN IN THE BILL.
KEY TALK ABOUT WHAT CHANGES ARE
MADE AND AND WHY YOU THINK
THEY'RE NECESSARY.
THE PLACE.
ANOTHER GREAT QUESTION SO
RELEVANT MARKET AREA RIGHT NOW
WITH THE LOW STATUTE SAYS IS
THAT.
A MANUFACTURER IT'S NOT ALLOWED
TO COMPETE AGAINST A DEALER OF
THE SAME LINE MAKE IN THE
RELEVANT MARKET AREA RELEVANT
MARKET AREAS DEFINED AS A TEN
MILE RADIUS AROUND. THE
DEALERSHIP THAT IS SET OUT IN
STATUTE.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN SEEN IS THAT
ONE MANUFACTURER STARTED SELLING
PARTS DIRECTLY ON AMAZON NOW OUR
PROBLEM ISN'T THE FACT THAT IT'S
BEING SOLD ON THE INTERNET? WE
DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT WE CARE IS
THAT A MANUFACTURER'S NOW
COMPETING AGAINST A DEALER BY
SELLING PARTS.
IN THEIR RELEVANT MARKET AREA SO
WE DISSOCIATION WROTE A LETTER.
TO GENERAL MOTORS EXCUSE ME THAT
MANUFACTURER AND PASSED THE
MANUFACTURER TO SPECIFICALLY
RESPOND TO OUR GATE ARE
ALLEGATIONS.
WE GOT THREE RISEN SENSUALLY
THREE RESPONSES IN THE LETTER
FIRST WAS IS.
WE'RE NOT SELLING PARTS ONLINE.
TWO IF WE WERE SELLING PARTS
ONLINE IS A STATUTE ISN'T CLEAR
ABOUT THAT WE CAN'T COMPETE
AGAINST YOU WANT PARKS AND THREE.
IF WE WERE SELLING ONLINE AND
THE STATUTE SAYS THERE WHERE ARE
PROHIBITED FROM SELLING PARTS.
WE'RE SELLING IT WITHIN THE
STATE NOT IRRELEVANT MARKET AREA
AND SO THE RESPONSE MY DEALER
SAID IS IS WAIT A MINUTE IF NOW
YOU CAN SELL THINGS ONLINE AND
IT'S NOT GOING IN MY RELEVANT
MARKET AREA AND IT'S GOING TO
THE STATE. THAT'S NOT FAIR THAT
UNDERMINES THE
IT'S A BASIC UNDERSTANDING WE
HAD ABOUT COMPETITION THAT ALSO
UNDERMINES CALIFORNIA STATUTE
AND SO WE DECIDED AND PASSED.
THE AUTHOR IF WE COULD CHANGE
THAT FROM RELEVANT MARKET AREA
TO SKATE THAT'S THE ONLY THING
WE DO IS TO TRY TO CAPTURE THE
ENEMY.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
FOCUSING.
MAY I RESPOND.
THINK YOU KNOW MARRIAGE OUT NOW
I'M SORRY BUT THAT'S NOT THE
WHERE IN THIS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU THANKS MONEY TO.
THE FINAL COMMENT YEAH NO MORE
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE EXPLANATION I
APPRECIATE IT I AM. WITH MY
FINAL COMMENT WILL BE STRIKES ME
THAT SOME OF THESE THINGS THAT
ARE BEING ASKED WE PUT THE
STATUTE MAY BE ABLE TO BE.
NEGOTIATED AND AND AND PUT TO A
CONTRACT THAT YOU HAVE WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS.
.
AND SO.
I THINK SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE BEEN SHARINGSOME OF THE
SAME I THINK IS A DESIRE THAT.
SOME GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATIONS
OCCUR TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES.
I THINK IF WE HAVE TO WILL
ADDRESS THEM BUT I THINK WE
PREFER THAT THAT THE GOOD FAITH.
SO NEGOTIATED PROCESS ADDRESS
SOME NUMBER OF THEM BEFORE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE WAY AND I THINK
IF YOU CONSIDERATION OF THAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSES
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
.
SEEN OTHER COMMENTS ALL JUST
MEET MIND I'M. VERY DISAPPOINTED
WITH THE.
OPPONENTS REACTION TO THE
QUESTION BY MY COLLEAGUE UP AND.
IT I FOUND IT INTERESTING WITH
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER BIGELOW.
USERNAME RIGHT.
I'M.
WHAT MR BONTA SAYS IS RIGHT BUT
YOU JUST TOLD US HE WON'T
NEGOTIATE?
I FIND THE DISPLAY BECAUSE
YESTERDAY YOU ARE MY OFFICE
ASKING FOR NEXT WEEK FOR
NEGOTIATIONS I TALK TO THE
AUTHOR SHE SUGGESTED TO ME THAT
THAT YOU YOU GUYS WEREN'T OPEN
NEGOTIATIONS THAT CLEARLY IS
TRUE. FROM WHAT I JUST HEARD IT
I WOULD SUGGEST SIR.
IN IN ITS VERY AYE AYE YOU.
LITERALLY HAVE NEVER HAD SOMEONE
SET.
THEY'RE LOSING SAYING WE WON'T
NEGOTIATE
SO I THINK YOU ARE.
HAVING DONE NEGOTIATIONS FOR A
LONG TIME IN MY PASSED OUT SO
YOU'RE IN A BAD SPOT.
AND THAT'S PROBABLY NOT AN
ATTITUDE. TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
IF YOU WANT TO ACTUALLY.
I NOT BE ROLLED OVER WITH THIS
BILL SO I I WOULD JUST SUGGEST
YOU YOU RETHINK THAT ATTITUDE
AND PERHAPS GIVE. THE AUTHOR THE
KIND OF RESPECT SHE DESERVES
AND ASKING TO COME TOGETHER OR
OR ELSE YOUR COMPLAINTS ARE
MEANINGLESS
YOU CAN'T SIT IN TULSA BUDDY YOU
YOU.
NOW MOTHER YOU HAVE TO TWO
POINTS YOU'RE ALLOWED TO MAKE IN
THIS BILL AND YOU HAVE TWENTY
FIVE THAT YOU'RE MAKING.
BECAUSE YOU MAY THINK YOU'RE
SAYING THAT TO THE SUPPORTERS
BUT YOU'RE SAYING THAT TO THE
AUTHOR THAT'S HIGHLY DISRESPECT.
SO.
IT'S HER BELT I SUGGEST YOU SIT
DOWN WITH HER THE SUPPORTERS AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK THE SPELL
SO. WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE MISTRESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THIS
BILL WILL CONTINUE TO EVOLVE AS
IT ALREADY HAS BEEN AMENDED. OUT
SEVERAL TIMES
I WILL OFFER ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
ON THE FLOOR ONCE THIS BILL
PASSES TODAY. ACCORDING TO THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS THIS BILL HAS
MINOR COSTS
AND AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND THAT BILL WAS
MOVED BY MISCREANTS SECOND BY
MISTER NAZARIAN AND GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL WITH MR BLOOM NOT
VOTING.
THANK YOU.
I WILL AT THIS POINT TAKE A
MOTION FOR MISS WEBBER SPELL AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO. SOARING
WE'RE BE NEXT WEEK IN JUST A
SECOND.
A MISTER WHAT IS BEING YOU ARE
SO GOOD.
MISTER WOULD YOU CAN BE NEXT
I'M SORRY ó UP FOR EIGHTY
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO MISS WEBER
SPELL THAT WAS MOVED BY MISTER
QUIRK SECOND BY MISS GRIOT.
I'M IN THAT IT'S OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN BY MR
HOLDEN.
MOVE I MISS CARILLO SECOND BY
MISTER QUIRK IN THAT GETS OUT OF
THE ROLL CALL WITH MR FUNG
VOTING ON A.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO BY
MISTER TEAM SO MOVED. MOVE AYE
AYE MR QUICK SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO IN THE CONTENT ON THE
ROLL CALL WITH MR FUNG NOT
VOTING.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX BY THE
CHAIR. SUCH A MOVE. THAT SOMEHOW.
MR QUIRK SECOND BY MISCREANT
LIKE IT'S OUT OF THE ROLL CALL
WITH MR FUNG NOT VOTING I THINK
THAT CATCHES US UP TO MISTER
WOULD.
.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU ARE PRESENTING
ON AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN.
ENJOY THE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
MOVE THE BILL.
SECOND I THINK WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY MISTER
QUIRK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF OF ALL PASS
ALL THE WAY FROM MY NINE OTHER
BILLS OF THEIR VERY FINE BILLS.
WE HOPE YOU CONSIDER THEM LATER.
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY IS DESIGNED
TO DO ONE THING ONE SIMPLE THING
SAVE LIVES.
IT REQUIRES HEALTH CARE
PRESCRIBERS WHEN ISSUE NOKIA
PRESCRIPTIONS TO PATIENTS
IDENTIFIED AT RISK TO OFF ALSO
OFFER THE LAW NALOXONE OPEN THE
LOCKS ON PRESCRIPTION.
THE WATSON IS AN OPIOID
ANTAGONISE AT AX IMMEDIATELY TO
REVERSE THE EFFECTS OF AN OPIATE
OVERDOSE.
THE SURGEON GENERAL UNITED
STATES FOR THE FOR AND IN HIS
FIRST NATIONAL ADVISORY SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIVE IN EMPHASIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE OVERDOSE
REVERSING DRUG THE LOCKS ON.
HE STATED THAT KNOWING HOW TO
USE NALOXONE KEEP IT WITHIN
REACH CAN SAVE A LIFE.
THREE OTHER STATES HAVE SIMILAR
LAWS A NUMBER OF STATES HAVE
BILLS PENDING AND AT LEAST
ELEVEN NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE CDC. AND THE AMA
RECOMMEND CHO PRESCRIBING.
NALOXONE WITH AT RISK.
TO.
THAT OPIATE PRESCRIPTIONS.
CONDITION IS SAVING LIVES THE
ABILITY TO REVERSE OVERDOSES
REDUCES HOSPITALIZATIONS AND THE
ASSOCIATED COSTS.
COULD ACTUALLY RESULT IN AN
OVERALL COST SAVINGS TO
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM ENCLOSING IT'S
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
INCREASING THE SURVIVAL RATE OF
THE PEOPLE PEOPLE EXPERIENCE AN
OVERDOSE. IS SIMPLE IT WORKS IT
SAVE LIVES I ASK DR OF.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MICHELLE
PREVIOUS WITH CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THE AVERAGE COST OF THE
NASAL AND ANTAGONISE IS A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
PER DOSE HOSPITAL STAY FAR
EXCEEDS THAT WE DO AGREE WITH
THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS THAT WE
BELIEVE THERE'S ABSOLUTE COSTS
EVEN POTENTIAL. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THINK YOU.
JENNIFER SOMOS AT THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
WILL PROMOTE THE BOARD MISSION A
CONSUMER PROTECTION THANK YOU IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NOT JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION YOUR POSITION
THAT'S HE ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JOE WARBLING CALIFORNIA CHRONIC
CARE COALITION IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SPENT SOME HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS WE HAVE OPPOSITION
FOR POLICY REASONS NOT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT BECAUSE GOOD IS
A TENNIS PLAYER IS GOOD. AS
SIMPLY BECAUSE HE'S LEGISLATING
THAT OPPOSITION HAS TO OFFER A
PRESCRIPTION AND AS A GENERAL
POLICY WE OPPOSE ANY BILL THAT
LEGISLATIVE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE
SO THANK YOU.
KIM.
MA'AM CHAIR TIM AND LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE MIRACLES
MERCY FISSIONS IN OPPOSITION FOR
LARGE THE SAME REASONS YOU JUST
STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NOVA. THINK YOU'RE.
DO I SKIP YOU LAST BILL.
PROBABLY HAD NO FILE. OKAY GOT.
THAT'S ON THE RECORD HAD NO FIVE
ON THE LIST BILL I'M SORRY WE
GOT SO HEATED.
IT USUALLY HAPPENS COMMITTEE.
.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS MISTER WHAT
WE GOT CLOSE RESPECT AFTER I
DON'T THINK YOU LIKE IT'S OUT ON
A ROLL CALL.
MISS BURKE.
YOU'LL BE PRESENT AND AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER EHSAN
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON BUT
THINK IN HERE TO PRESENT ITS
ILLEGAL THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CURRENTLY IN
RECEIVERSHIP TO USE REVENUES
FROM THE SALE OF SURPLUS
PROPERTY FOR PAYING DOWN THE
LOAN. AMOUNT OWED TO THE STATE
AS POSSIBLE NO I HAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT INCLUDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT HAS BEEN IN STATE
RECEIVERSHIP FOR SIX YEARS. IT
TIED P TREMENDOUS UPS AND DOWNS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY STATE
RECEIVERSHIP SET SCHOOLS UP TO
FAIL THIS WOULD ALLOW THE.
THIS WITHOUT ALLOW SOME
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY BUT THAT ANNA
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
IN SUPPORT GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. WILD
INGLEWOOD UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS UNDER STATE
RECEIVERSHIP THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
PARTNERS WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THEIR SOLVENCY AND
EVENTUAL RETURN. TO LOCAL
CONTROL AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
THINK AB THREE TWO TWO EIGHT
WILL HELP ACHIEVE THAT GOAL SO
WE ARE JUST SUPPORT.
I HAD THIS BEEN AWESOME TO HAVE
A STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARDS AND
SPONSOR OF. AB THREE TWO TWO
EIGHT. OF THE BILL WILL BE FOR.
JUST TO BE. A BRIEF.
THE THE BILL WILL FOCUS ON THE
FOUR DISTRICTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER RECEIVERSHIP
WHICH ARE OAKLAND INGLEWOOD.
VALLEJO KING CITY UNIFIED
FORMERLY KNOWN AS SOUTH MONTEREY
COUNTY.
UNIFIED DISTRICT.
AB THREE TWO TWO EIGHT WERE
AVAILABLE PROVIDE THESE. EASE
DISTRICTS TO WRITE WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE MONEY AND
REPAY THE LOAN AND MINIMIZE THE
IMPACT TO TO THE CLASSROOM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
PETTY HERRERA PRESENTING OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT STILL
STRUGGLING TO GET OUT FROM UNDER
RECEIVERSHIP SO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THINK
HIM.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
XENON DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSENESS I RESPECT LIKE WATSON
I WILL. AND I GET OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH MR FUNG AND MR
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU.
MISTER NAZARIAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO NEXT.
SO.
MR NAZAR YOUR PRESENT AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY THREE ENJOYS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED.
SECOND TO CLARIFY THE PHARMACY
BENEFIT MANAGER IS SUBJECT TO
REGULATION AS A SUBCONTRACTOR.
CONTRACTOR OF A PLAN OR IN SURE.
I ASSUME YOU'RE GONNA ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS. THAT WAS GONNA
BE MICE TALKING POINT.
AS WE HAVE A MOTION.
BY MYSTERIOUS A SECOND BY
MISTER BIGELOW YOU MAY PROCEED.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE.
YOUR WORK AND COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS I ACCEPT THEM AND.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IN SUPPORT.
SHE WHISPERED QUIETLY REPRESENT
IN CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL. WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE HOUSE WE LIVE
IN.
MANAGER TO MATTER REVERSING THE
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY LINE
SINCE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
MACHAR READ THIS CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
Q..
RIGHT SPENCER CALIFORNIA CATNIP
FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NOVELL.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS REJECT CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN.
MR CHILL.
MISTER CHAU YOUR PRISONER AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SECOND WE HAVE MOTION BY
MYSTERIOUS A SECOND BY MISTER
QUIRK.
SEAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR VERY
QUICKLY THIS IS A BILL TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
BY REQUIRING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
STREAMLINED APPROVAL OF A
HUNDRED PERCENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS THAT
INCLUDE A MINIMUM PERCENTAGE OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WHICH HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO BE. THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF ADDRESSING
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS THE. OTHER
IS NO STATE FISCAL IMPACT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COULD RECOUP
ANY COSTS THROUGH FEES AND
WITHOUT RESPECT WE ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
GIVE SUPPORTERS.
WHERE WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY?
SUPPORT.
TYRONE BUCKLEY WOULD HOUSING
NO ALSO HERE'S STRONG SUPPORT.
CITY GEORGE WITH AMERICAN PLANE
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BETTER CHAIR MEMBERS PLAYER BE
HAVE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO SUPPORT FOR MANY WE'RE
GONNA KEEP WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
BUT LOVE THE BILL. OR DRIVE OF.
THINKING.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TIM SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
KIM MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SYLVIA SOLELY SEAN BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERG OR SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION IN
SUPPORT.
IT'S VERY CITY OF LONG BEACH IN
OPPOSITION.
IN OPPOSITION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK TO YOUR OPPOSITION.
NOW YOU JUST WANNA REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION.
OKAY IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FILE.
MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
RESPECT ASK YOUR SUPPORT TO GET
OUT OF THE ROLL CALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
DEAN NO AUTHORS OF MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU WANTED TO PRESENT
ON A SUSPENSE BILL.
YOU'LL BE PRISON ON AB THIRTY
FORTY FIVE.
AND WE ARE JUST SO IT IS CLEAR
WE'RE WAITING ON MR KANSEN CHU.
MISS RUBIO WHO I KNOW WAS HERE
BEFORE.
THAT'S IT.
IT PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND THEN AS YOU KNOW I WOULD NOT
NORMALLY PRESENT A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE VATOS PRETTY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT I JUST WANTED TO
BRING ATTENTION TO THE COMMITTEE.
I AB THIRTY FORTY FIVE.
IS THE ONLY SUSPENSE CANADA
THAT I WILL PRESENT IN ON THIS
YEAR AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES BRIEF ATTENTION.
AT THIS BILL WOULD CREATE AN
INDEPENDENT BODY.
TO OVERSEE THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AS PROPOSED BY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN.
AS A TO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FAILURE OF THE OROVILLE SPILLWAY
SHOWED CALIFORNIA MUST DO BETTER.
IN MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION OF
THE STATE WATER PROJECT.
MANY OF YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THAT
THE FORENSIC TEAM THAT
INVESTIGATED THAT DISASTER FOUND
THAT ORGANIZATIONAL FACTORS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES CONTRIBUTED TO THAT
FAILURE. THE FACTORS INCLUDED
OVER OVER CONFIDENCE ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT A REACTIVE VERSUS
PROACTIVE APPROACH TO PROJECT
MANAGEMENT. AND COST CONTROL
PRESSURES.
AT IS QUICKLY LIKE TO PLAN A
COUPLE THINGS THAT WERE.
KEY FINDINGS THAT WE SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION TO.
ONE THERE WAS A THERE WAS A VERY
CLEAR DESIGN FLAW IN THIS BILL
AND AS IT WAS CONSTRUCTED THAT
EVERY EXPERT THAT'S LOOKED AT
THIS.
HAS SAID THIS SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN DONE AND IS THAT WHAT IT IS
IS EMBEDDING THE DRAINS IN THIS
BILL WAY CONSIDERING THE
GEOLOGIC CONDITIONS UP THERE.
AND WHAT SHOULD BUT NOT AT THE
TIME THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
NOTICED AS A DESIGN FLAW.
EW ARE NEVER LOOKED BACK AT THE
AS BILLS OR THE DESIGNS OF THE
PROJECT.
AND SO THIS CONTINUE TO BE GO.
UNNOTICED AND UNRECOGNIZED.
AT THE DEPARTMENT.
CRACKING THAT CONTINUALLY
HAPPENED EVERY TEN YEARS ON THE
SPILLWAY.
SHOULD HAVE RAISE RED FLAGS
THIS WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE
REPORT. AB WAS IT INSTEAD
NORMALIZED.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
AND THE OVER CONFIDENCE FACTOR
NINE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN.
SIM AND PUBLIC INTEREST GROUPS
RECOGNIZE.
AT HERB BROUGHT TO.
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
ATTENTION THAT THERE WERE
GEOLOGIC ISSUES WITH WHETHER OF
ROCK ON THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY.
DE W. R. RESPONDED AND SAID NO
THIS IS BUILT ON COMPETENT ROCK.
AND ACTUALLY RESPONDED WITH AN
ATTACHMENT TO ONE OF THEIR MEMOS.
SHOWING SOME OF THE GEOLOGIC LE.
BOREN'S
IF THEY WERE TO LOOK CLOSER AT
THOSE ACTUAL BORING'S THAT THEY
SHOWED THAT THEY ACTUALLY GAVE A.
TO FOR THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN
THAT THERE WAS GEOLOGIC.
WEATHERED ROCK IN THOSE
FORMATIONS.
SO THERE'S SOME VERY SERIOUS
ISSUES HERE AND IT RAISES
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THE ENTIRE
PROJECT BEING. OPERATED
REGULATORY DECISIONS ARE
ULTIMATELY.
THAT UNDER CURRENT LAW THE STATE
WATER PROJECT IS OWNED AND
OPERATED BY THE DEPARTMENT. IT'S
ALSO REGULATED AND INSPECTED BY
THEIR DIVISION OF THEM SAFETY.
AND THIS IS BY ONE OF THE ONLY
PLACES I'VE SEEN WHERE WE THE
OWNER AND OPERATOR ALSO
REGULATES.
THE SAME PROJECT REGULATORY
DECISIONS ARE ALSO WE MADE BY
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
WHO ALSO ACTS AS A WATER MANAGER.
IS INHERENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
THAT THE OWNER OF THE PROJECT.
IS ALSO THE REGULAR MOVED MOVING
FORWARD.
MY MOVING THE PROJECT TO AN
INDEPENDENT BODY NOT ONLY
REMOVES THIS CONFLICT OF
INTEREST BUT IT ALSO INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY.
ABOUT PROJECT OPERATIONS AND I
THINK THIS IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
POINT.
IN THE.
IN THE INDEPENDENT FORENSIC
REPORT IT STATED THAT WHAT THERE
WAS COST PRESSURES
APPLY TO YOU W. OR BY THE WATER
CONTRACTORS THEY WERE NOT
SPECIFIC AS TO WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY SAID THESE ISSUES MAY HAVE
BEEN RAISED IN MEETINGS HERE'S
THE PROBLEM A LOT OF THOSE MEANS
ARE NOT PUBLIC.
THIS INDEPENDENT COMMISSION
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO BAGLEY KEENE
AND THEREFORE THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE WOULD BE MUCH
MORE TRANSPARENT.
TO THE PEOPLE OF THIS STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S IN OUT LIAR IN ITS
MANAGEMENT THE STATE WATER
PROJECT OTHER LARGE SCALE STATE
PROJECTS ARE RUN BY INDEPENDENT
AND.
DECISIONS ABOUT THESE PROJECTS
ARE MADE IN PUBLIC MEETINGS BY
INDEPENDENT BODIES THAT
REPRESENT STATEWIDE INTERESTS.
MY ALSO MATCHES HERE'S THIS IS
BETTER OPERATIONS NOT JUST FOR
ORVILLE BUT FOR EVERYBODY IN
THIS STATE WHO RELIES ON THAT
WATER IF YOU ARE A WATER
CONTRACTOR IF YOU LIVE IN A. AN
AREA THAT STE GETS ITS WATER BY
THE WATER FROM THE WATER
CONTRACTORS. USUALLY HAVE AN
INTEREST IN THIS BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW.
THE COST OF THIS REPAIRED
ORVILLE OF WHAT HAPPENED UP
THERE.
WHATEVER FEMA DOESN'T COVER AND
RIGHT NOW IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
THEY ARE GOING TO COVER THAT
COMPLETE COST GETS PASSED ON TO
GUESS WHAT THE CONSUMER.
SO WE ALL HAVE AN INTEREST IN
ENSURING.
NOW OUR WILL THAT DID THIS
PROJECT IS OPERATE EFFICIENTLY
AND SAFELY.
AND SO.
THAT IS WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US OPEN OF THIS
CONVERSATION AND I WOULD ASK.
ULTIMATELY FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
GETTING THIS BILL OFFICES SPENT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THEY GIVE ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
I'M GONNA.
ALLOW TWO MINUTES.
FROM TWO FOLKS IF THEY WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT I WANNA REMIND
PEOPLE THIS IS NOT A POLICY
COMMITTEE THOUGH AND TO KEEP ON
THOSE COMMENTS KILL. FISCAL
MATTERS ONLY VERY BRIEFLY THE
MEDICARE PLAYER TRIED
ARRANGEMENT WE HAVE THE BICU
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THIS REALLY IS THE DISTRICT
BILL OF ALL THAT YOUR BILL IF
YOU HAD A DAMN. OTHER WAS ABOVE
SO MANY PEOPLE SO MANY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR DISTRICT I
THINK EVERY SINGLE MEMBER
LEGISLATURE WILL BE RUNNING A
BILL LIKE THIS WOULD HAPPEN MUCH
YOU WITH THE EVACUATION.
CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO HAPPEN
AGAIN YOU COUNTY BOARD
SUPERVISORS IS VERY GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER FOR
RUNNING THIS BILL NEITHER DRIVE
VOTE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SEEN NONE OPPOSITION TWO MINUTES
TO PEOPLE.
FISCAL MATTERS ONLY PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JACK WHILE CHO THE QUIRK AGREE
BUT BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY
WATER AGENCY.
ALAMEDA COUNTIES ON SEVEN WATER
AGENCY AND SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT AND THE.
LONG BEACH WATER DEPARTMENT HERE
IN OPPOSITION AND
MINDFUL OF YOUR ADMONITION TIED
TO A. DWELL ON POLICY.
LET ME JUST INDICATE THAT THE
STATE WATER PROJECTS NOT A PLUG
AND PLAY. A CASSETTE TAPE EIGHT
TRACK OR VHS
A TO GO BACK IN THE DAY IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S INTERTWINED
FULLY WITH EVERY.
BIT OF OPERATION OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECTS SO.
LOOKING AT THE EMPLOYEE BASE OF
THE DEPARTMENT ALONE TO EXTRACT
THE STATE WATER PROJECT IS GOING
TO LEAVE.
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF STRANDED
COST AND.
THE ANALYSIS QUICKLY AND
POINTEDLY MAKES THAT CASEY HAD
WE WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THAT
DID YOU EVALUATE THIS BILL LOSS
ON SUSPEND SO. FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION.
JIM MR JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE
METROPOL WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION JUST BILL THEY'LL
WOOD MISTER WALKER SHARED.
NOT ONLY DO YOU HAVE THIS
INTERTWINING YOU HAVE FOLKS OUT
PWR THAT SPLIT THEIR TIME BOTH
BETWEEN STATE WATER PROJECT AND
NON STATE WATER PROJECT HUGE
COSTS OF HAVING COMPLETELY SPLIT
THAT OUT. AS WELL WITHIN THOSE
CONTRACTS FOR THE CONTRACTORS WE
WILL NOT BE BEARING THE COST OF
MAKING THE SWITCH TO THERE'S
HUGE GENERAL FUND PRESSURES BY
MAKING THE SWITCH.
AND WITH THAT. IN MY TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU ADDITION OPPOSITION
NAME TITLE AND POSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AT MANY KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY IN
OPPOSITION.
AND CHAIR MEMBERS RON DAVIS ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT IN EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT OFFICE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JOHN
O'MALLEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY. MW DEAL POST.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THAT'S A
LOSS ON BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY AND CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THINK CAMP DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
THAT. MR EGGMAN HOW QUESTION
FIRST IN THE MISTER QUIRK.
I THINK YOU THAT IT MANAGER I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A OF A COMMENT
I THINK TO AS WE SPEAK TODAY AND
I APPRECIATE ALL THE FOLKS FROM
DOWN SOUTH WHO GOT UP TO SPEAK.
UP BECAUSE ORVILLE SERVES AS THE
COP THAT PEOPLE WANT TO PLUG A
GIANT STRAW INTO AS I UNDERSTAND
TODAY PEOPLE ARE UNDERTAKING.
CONTRACTORS HAVE GPAS TO IT TO
CREATE THE LOW END A SEVENTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR PROJECT THAT WE
STILL DON'T KNOW HOW IT'S GOING
TO BE PAID FOR.
SO FOR SOME FINANCIAL FUNDING SO
PERHAPS IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BUILDING SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR STRAWS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT FEED INTO A
MISTER GALLAGHER'S DISTRICT THEN
MAYBE WE LET THEM FOR THE FATHER
FEATHER FALLS POWER DISTRICT UP
THERE. BE ABLE TO RUN THAT IF
WE'RE GONNA BE START TO LOCALIZE
OUT HOW WE RUN OUR PROJECTS I
THINK WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK
COMPREHENSIVELY AT
THE COST FOR CALIFORNIANS. AND
HOW WE MAKE THOSE THINGS WORK SO
I APPLIED YOU'RE A CREATIVE WAY
OF GOING ABOUT THIS AND I THINK
WE NEED TO HAVE A LOT MORE CALM.
MR MARKETS AND YEAH. IBM I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT DAM SAFETY.
AND I REALLY AS I SAID TO YOU
LAST NIGHT PREFERRED YOUR FIRST
BILL WHICH IS MUCH CHEAPER WHICH
IS SIMPLY THE MOVE THE. DAM
SAFETY GROUP OVER TO NATURAL
RESOURCES I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
WAY.
TAKE CARE OF IT AND AGAIN IT
WOULD BE A LOT CHEAPER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK.
NO MORE COMMENTS WHICH I TOOK
CONCLUDE AND THANK YOU MADAM.
CHAIR CHAIRWOMAN.
AND I WOULD I WOULD SAY YES
THIS IS A MAJOR REFORM LOT OF
MOVING PARTS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
WHEN WE CAN HAVE IT CONSIDERING
WHAT'S ALL TRANSPIRED HERE
LATELY SO THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
AND I JUST ASK FOR. YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON SUSPENSE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AND I'M JUST GOING TO
SPENCE.
MISS RUBIO YOUR NEXT.
WE'LL BE PRESENTING ON A. B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING.
WEAVERVILLE.
LEAVE IT MOTION BY MISTAKE WHEN
A SECOND BY MISS CRIA UM WELL AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT UPDATES
ARE DOOR ADVERTISEMENT.
ADVERTISING LANDSCAPE FREEWAY
ACT TO GIVE CITIES FLEXIBILITY
TO OBTAIN OUTDOOR ADVERTISEMENT
SIGNS WITHOUT INCREASING THE
CURRENT NUMBER OF BILLBOARDS
ALONG LANDSCAPE FREEWAYS. BY
ALLOWING A LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
REALLY.
RELOCATE A LEGALLY PERMITTED
DISPLAY FROM ONE LANDSCAPE
FREEWAY TO IT OF SECTION TO
ANOTHER. AND SINCE I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND I DO HAVE.
THAT SEE MAKING LOW PER.
HERE AND I HAVE.
RETIRED A CHIEF COUNSEL OF
RONALD BILLS DEALS FROM LA
CALTRANS FOR IT TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
MADAM CHAIR MAKING LOW FROM HALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ACT OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
RUN. RUN MEALS AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
BUILD A PLACE YOU ONLY HAVE TO
THE CITY OF ARTESIA HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EITHER ANY OPPONENTS.
SEEN NONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOVA.
PROJECT CONCLUDED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
ON THIS MATTER AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHERE. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
MR SHOW YOUR PRISONER AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY NINE IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
MOVE THE BILL.
THE MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AND A
SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK SEKHEMRE
THEN SHARE SOME MEMBERS AB
TWENTY TWO AND I CAN I CALL
DEFIED THE SIX GRADE READING
LEVEL REQUIREMENTS. PULL MORE
BUT FOR MEDI CAL HEALTH
EDUCATION AND INFORMATION
DOCUMENT IN ENGLISH.
IT ALSO EXTEND THIS REQUIREMENT
TO STRUCTURAL LANGUAGES TO
ENSURE THAT READABILITY AND
APPROPRIATENESS OF THE WRITTEN
COMMUNICATION HERE WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY. SUPPORT IS JAN
FLOORING WAS THAT WESTERN CENTER
AL LAW AND PROPERTY AND CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. AND
KIMBERLY CHAMBLISS TO CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CAN REALLY
TELL THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH THE
FELLOWS OF THE WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE. WHICH OTHER COAST ONE
A CO SPONSORS ON THE BILL THIS
BILL REFLECTS THEIR EXPERIENCES
FELLOW AS ADVOCATES OF AND
HEALTH IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES
AND THE MINOR COSTS WILL GO A
LONG WAY IN ENSURING. A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN BE THE
BEST ADVOCATES FOR THEIR OWN
HOUSE
AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHEN FLOOR IN
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THIS I JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT YOU
KNOW WE REALLY ARE BUILDING ON
EXISTING STRUCTURES THE BILL HAS
BEEN FOUND TO HAVE MINIMAL COSTS.
WERE REALLY BASICALLY MARRYING
THE IDEA OF READABILITY AT
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES SO IT'S NOT
JUST ENGLISH SECONDS READABLE
DOCUMENTS BUT ALL THRESHOLDING
WHICH IS GET READABLE DOCUMENTS.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING YOU KNOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
THAT DOCUMENTS ARE PRIORITIZE
ONCE IT ALREADY BEEN FIELD
TESTED CAN.
.
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN FIELD
TESTED CAN BE DE PRIORITIZING
THAT WITH LATER AND THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE ONES THAT
ACTUALLY NEED THE COMMUNITY
REVIEW FIRST.
AND IN ADDITION PLANTS HAD
ASKED ABOUT YOU KNOW IF THEY HAD
TO DO THIS COUNTY BY COUNTY AND
SO WE ARE ACCEPTING THE.
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AT THIS
JUST BE DONE ON A THRESHOLD
LANGUAGE BASIS.
YES I THINK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARY ABOUT THIS WITH HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA. ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WHEN.
CONSUMERS CAN READ THEIR
INFORMING MATERIALS ARE BETTER
ABLE TO ACCESS TO CARE SUMMER IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOT ONE OVER ON ME
TESTIFYING.
OPPOSITION IS VERY OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY BECAUSE
OF THE COMMENTS WE WE DISCUSSED
AMENDMENTS I THINK OUR COMMITTEE
TO DISCUSS POSSIBLE WAYS TO TO
CLEAR UP THIS BILL. WE'VE NOT
RECOMMENDED ARE WE HAVE BEEN
FORCED AMENDMENTS.
AND SO IF IF MISTER CHU IS
TAKING THOSE HE WILL HAVE TO
TAKE THEM ON THE FLOOR IN THEIR
GOOD FAVOR MY TRANSACTION.
APOLOGIES FOR THE COULD.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND ARE YOU
TAKING OUT THE ENGLISH SIXTH
GRADE NO NO NO I'M NOT KEEPING
THAT IN. YES SO IT MIGHT BE YOM.
I'M JUST CONCERNED THAT PERHAPS
YOU CAN'T GET ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION INTO SIXTH GRADE
LEVEL.
.
AND IT MIGHT BE CHEAPER TO DO IT
IF IT WERE NINTH GRADE LEVEL I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY
SIXTH GRADE SIX GRADE HAS BEEN A
STANDARD.
IT IS DIFFICULT IN DEALING WITH.
HEALTH DOCUMENTS BUT IT'S A
STANDARD THAT'S ACHIEVABLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
SEE MEMBERS CHILI GOTTA.
FOR GIVE VERY MUCH SO OF I URGE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND THAT GETS OUT OF
THE ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER.
IT'S TIME I AM I WILL TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BY MISTER BIGELOW SECOND BY
MISTER CALDERON.
MEMSIC TAKING PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE TWENTY
SIXTY THREE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE.
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWENTY THREE
NINETY. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY TO. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FIFTY EIGHT. THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT AND THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN.
THANK YOU.
AT THIS TO SO THAT GETS OUT I'M
SORRY I'M ON A ROLL CALL AND.
I'M.
AT THIS POINT MAN SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE READ THE BILL'S
MOVING INTO SUSPENSE WHERE THE
PRESENTATIONS HAVE BEEN WIPED.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY THREE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE NINETEEN TWELVE NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE. NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN NINETEEN FIFTY TO NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. SEVEN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY TWENTY NINE
TWENTY FORTY NINE TWENTY FIFTY
SIX TWENTY SIXTY NINE TWENTY
SEVENTY SEVEN. TWENTY NINETY ONE
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE SIXTY SIX
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY SIX.
TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE TWENTY
TWO OR THREE TWENTY TWO OR SEVEN
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
TWO NINETY SEVEN. THREE THREE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT TWENTY
THREE FIFTY TWO. TWENTY THREE
FIFTY FIVE TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE TWENTY
THREE SIXTY SIX.
THREE THREE SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY. THREE THREE EIGHTY TO
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR THIRTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE.
TWENTY FIVE A ONE TWENTY FEDERAL
TO TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY THREE. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN. TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX
FORTY ONE TWENTY SIX FORTY THREE
TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE TWENTY SIX
FIFTY TWO. TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN. TWENTY
SEVEN OCT TWO TWENTY SEVEN NO
THREE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT DIRECTORY TWENTY
THIRTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT POINT
TWO TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY SIX TWENTY NINE OH FIVE
TWENTY NINE ELEVEN. TWENTY NINE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY NINE FOUR.
THREE NINE FORTY SIX TWENTY NINE
FIFTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE SIXTEEN
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY SIX TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY NINE TWENTY NINE
NINETY NINE. THREE THOUSAND
THREE THOUSAND SIXTY THOUSAND
NINE THREE THOUSAND THIRTY FORTY
FIVE THIRTY FORTY EIGHT. THREE
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR
THIRTY SIX SEVENTY SIX THIRTY
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE.
THIRTY NINETY SIX THIRTY ONE TEN
THIRTY ONE ELEVEN. THIRTY ONE
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE FORTY ONE
THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR THIRTY ONE
FORTY FIVE THIRTY ONE FIFTY TWO
THIRTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY FIVE THIRTY ONE
NINETY THREE. THIRTY TO ONE
THIRTY TILL SEVEN THIRTY TO NINE
THIRTY TO THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO
THIRTY THREE.
THANK YOU AND SECRETARY IF.
ANYBODY WISHES TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON
ANY OF THE BILLS THAT WERE MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE THAT THE
AUTHOR WAY PRESENTATION.
YOU CAN
IMPORTS MICROPHONE NOW AND DO SO.
JUST YOUR NAME AND.
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON WHICH
BILL GOOD MORNING AYE LISKI ON
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES BY I WOULD
LIKE TO.
RESPECTFULLY A REGISTRAR OUR
OPPOSITION TO A. B. THIRTY
NINETY SIX.
WITH REGARD TO THE SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT CARD
THINKING.
BUT I'M CHAIR RYAN SHIRLEY WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN.
A MAN CHAIR SAMPRAS REPRESENTING
GUN OWNERS CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE TO.
I DON'T CHAIR DAN RE WITH
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO.
A DENNIS SEATON PATRISTIC
COUNCIL SUPPORTER OF. AB TWENTY
NINE FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU. SEEN NOBODY ELSE THAT
CONCLUDES OUR APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING.
MEETING ADJOURNED